うーん今日は毒っていう
始めたというわけで今日の実験はですがこちらの方にも有名なんですね木工用ボンド
ボンドの子に子さんって会社とのタイアップでございますついに俺も
ボンド業界に更新しするようにがどんどん小西さんなんでちょっとあの
成功しなきゃヤバイ今回の成功しなきゃヤバイ実験が今日の実験はいたって簡単だ
みんなんハンモックップ知ってるからなきっと何か物と物2個つなげてをぷらんぷらん
てな猫のベッドみたいなやつがあるんだなぁ今この僕の手元にあるものがこちらの女の
の切れ端しかないんですよね大実の黒いのと白いでのしかないのでこれで
だけだとハンモックを作れないようなこの布しかない状況では俺は今日ハンモックを
作ろうと思う用意するものはこちら
今日さんこんなたくさんお裁縫ジョーズというね接着剤接着剤があるんですけどもこの
際放生津という接着剤を使って今日はこの布をくっつけて白黒がちょうどあるんで
後ろクロス
6乗ってこれをくっつけてシマシマ模様のハンモックをつくって実際に僕がそこに乗っ
てみようと思いますすぐ
接着剤でハンモック作ってみたいつもの私の実験だったらこれはたぶん失敗するんです
よ
接着剤が弱くてフィンみたいな三世終わるんですけどもこちらの妻北条2とても強力な
接着剤になって
かばんを作ったり場札とがで本とかレースをつけたりズボンスカート諏訪下にも使え
ます
アイロンね高熱を与えてあげるとさらに強力にねくっつくと洗濯とかねドライ
クリーニングをしても履けないんですよ
なぜこれが最放生津かというと裁縫セット針とかうぬよりもボンドだけでくっつけて
離れなくなる
ひょっとしたら服を縫う時代が多い
あるかもしれんそういう画期的な超強力な接着剤なんです異論などに対応しているので
この
今回僕が持っているこれにもしっかりくっつけて離れなくなるポニーさんの会社の実験
によりますと2.5かける2.5センチの接着3月これでねこれでの接着明晰で250
キロの引張試験
250キロで引っ張っても取れませんでしたと言う
結果がありますそれぐらいつけただけでも250点を与えられるということは計算に
よるとボケが乗っても全然余裕で韓服の祈りで接着剤だけで反応会が作れる時代なん
ですよ
実に楽しみだ鳩よけて早速こちらの西方像を使ってですね
高め成功してくる
あのちょっと企業的にも個人的にも成功してほしい動画ですでは
行こう
ピンピン根拠しては早速作っていこう今回は強力に接着させるということなので
アイロンを使っていきましょう
まずは春ところの行名を塗っていきます
持って打って守って
市児童書2た貼り合わせます
俺書生者だからわかるんだよおっすおっ家でこの7でも靴んですけどもよりより強い
強度を求めるためにはですね大きめのアテネ通して家庭用アイロンアイロンで15秒
から20秒こう
くっつけます i 色合いのうおいおい温度10くらいでこう当てて15秒から20秒
ほど
動かさずにこの木付
ますね
これを全体でになっていきます
特に一応完成したんですけどを不器用なオイラでもなかなかグッドな仕上がりだと思い
ますここで
離れる気がしないクラシックりっ
おりますすごいでしょ接着剤だけどこれ接着剤でこれよ
ただみんな分かっていると思うがこれでほんまんじゃない序章何人か5624なる
ちょっと読んで実際に韓服がここでは作れないので
4人に端っこ4カ所持ってもらってそこで僕絡めますで寝るどうも本当に野菜4畳2間
だ
すごいつの
接着力はむちゃくちゃ撮影テープの証明なので本当に再訪ちょっとの強さを証明して
みようと思います
いきます
つい
っていう
和光堂突から体重もすればいいか分からないよねはい
まったりまだまだてちょっとラセゾンすごい大丈夫か本当に切れない偽善って言ってい
ます
twitter 21
4 o m e
goo
noh
すごい交えた全単射強い z になんで鞄とローで前に進むと思いますで皆さんも実際
に
必要なしかけたらいいと思いますばいばーい
ええええええ
は恒例のでも
強い堅調ちゃっち方や強すぎ布が先に破けるぐらいの強さです
おっ
me